hasta ahora hemos visto reacciones de
sustitución electro física aromática
involucrando solo benceno pero qué
sucede cuando empiezas con un sustituye
ente ya en tu anillo de benceno veremos
esta molécula aquí en la izquierda la
cual es met ocs y benceno ahora tenemos
un sustituyen te meto cxi en nuestro
anillo de benceno y si reaccionamos meto
c's y benceno con ácidos nítrico y
sulfúrico concentrados debemos de
reconocer que siendo una reacción de ni
tracción instalada un grupo nitro en tu
anillo aromático la presencia de ese
sustituyen teme tóxico
afectará en donde estará a tu grupo
nitro en tu anillo por ejemplo uno de
los productos observados es poner el
grupo nitro en este carbono el cual es
el carbono justo al lado del carbono que
tiene nuestro sustituyen teme tóxico
decimos que estos dos grupos son [ __ ] el
uno al otro así que esto sería el
producto [ __ ]
si vuelvo a este diagrama de aquí puedo
etiquetar este carbono como el que está
en la posición [ __ ] en mi anillo de
benceno el otro producto que observamos
es un grupo nitro instalado en este
carbono el cual está en el lado opuesto
al carbono que tiene nuestro sustituyen
teme tóxico lo llamamos producto va
déjame continuar y etiquetar la posición
para
en nuestro anillo de benceno aquí esta
sería la posición para entre el producto
[ __ ] y el para resulta ser que el
producto para es el producto principal
observado en la reacción de ni tracción
del met ox y benceno y el producto [ __ ]
es el producto
con
da frío
y esto tiene que ver sobre todo en
pensar en el impedimento estético y este
grupo med occ si está teniendo algo de
impedimento estético lo cual obviamente
prevendrá que este grupo nitro se añada
a la posición [ __ ] fácilmente obviamente
la posición para tendrá mucho menos
impedimento estético y esa es la razón
que normalmente ves por la cual el
producto para será el producto principal
para esta reacción ahora este no es
siempre el caso
algunas veces tu producto [ __ ] es más
que tú para pero para esta reacción el
producto para es el principal y
nuevamente el impedimento estético es un
factor en que pensar cuando estás
haciendo este tipo de reacciones aquí
por supuesto hay otra posición en tu
anillo aromático si instalamos el grupo
nitro en esta posición llamaremos a esto
el producto
y el producto metano se observa con un
alto rendimiento para esta reacción
decimos que el grupo med occ si es un
director corto para y también podríamos
etiquetar esto como la posición [ __ ] de
este lado y podríamos decir que esto es
la posición meta debido a la simetría
pero el producto meta no se ve en un
gran rendimiento en un alto rendimiento
y continuamos dibujando un montón de
estructuras resonantes y pensando en el
mecanismo para la sustitución electro
física aromática y entonces continuemos
empezando con un ataque corto
y sabemos que cuando estás haciendo una
ni tracción el ácido sulfúrico actúa
como catalizador para generar el yoni
troneo a partir de ácido nítrico y eso
funciona como el electro filo en este
mecanismo de aquí si hacemos un ataque
[ __ ] necesitamos mostrar el grupo nitro
añadiéndose a la posición [ __ ] así que
necesitamos mostrar al grupo nitro
añadiéndose a este carbono y si el grupo
nitro se añadirá a este carbono entonces
estos son los electrones peak que pueden
funcionar como núcleo filo en nuestro
mecanismo tenemos una reacción núcleo
filo electro filo para el primer paso de
nuestro mecanismo el núcleo filo estos
electrones y atacarán es centro gen o
cargado positivamente lo cual mueve
estos electrones a este oxígeno
si dibujamos el resultado de ese ataque
núcleo físico
aún tenemos nuestro sustituyen te meto
c's y aquí arriba
estoy mostrando el grupo micro
agregándose a la posición [ __ ] y
recuerda que hay un hidrógeno unido a
ese carbono
tengo electrones vi por aquí electrones
por aquí y estoy diciendo que estos
electrones que son los que formaron un
enlace con este nitrógeno así
eso quita un enlace de este carbono por
lo que ese carbono obtiene una carga
formal de más 1
podemos mostrar algunas estructuras
resonantes podemos mostrar algo de
estabilización por resonancia de este
camión de aquí podría mostrar estos
electrones moviéndose a acá y podríamos
dibujar otra estructura resonante
continuamos mostrando en
movimiento de esos electrones pi
a esta posición déjame continuar
dibujando el resto del guión
aquí
tenemos un hidrógeno aquí tenemos un no2
aquí y tomamos estos electrones pide
aquí los movimos a esta posición
quitamos un enlace de ese carbono
obtenemos una carga formal de 1 en este
carbono y esa es otra estructura
resonante podemos dibujar otra podemos
mostrar el movimiento de estos
electrones y acá continuamos mostrando
eso tenemos nuestro anillo
tenemos nuestro grupo med occ sí
tenemos nuevamente el grupo nitro
en la posición norte y tenemos estos
electrones de aquí
y ahora mostramos el movimiento de esos
electrones vi a acá déjame continuar
resaltando los estos electrones en rojo
se movieron a acá abajo quité un enlace
de este carbono este carbono es el que
obtiene ahora una carga formal de uno ya
que el oxígeno está justo al lado de
este carbono
el oxígeno tiene un par libre de
electrones y ese par libre de electrones
nos puede dar aún otra estructura
resonante estos electrones podrían
moverse para acá
para dibujar una cuarta estructura
resonante la presencia de heces
sustituyen teme tóxico con el par libre
de electrones en ese oxígeno te permite
dibujar una cuarta estructura resonante
esto dará a este oxígeno una carga
formal de más 1 tenemos estos electrones
pib de aquí tenemos nuestro grupo micro
otra vez en la posición [ __ ] y déjame
continuar mostrando el movimiento de
esos electrones estos electrones los
haré verdes estos electrones de aquí se
moverán para formar nuestro enlace y así
y tenemos un total de cuatro estructuras
resonantes posibles recuerda que el
guión es de hecho un híbrido de estas
cuatro estructuras resonantes
el cual llamamos nuestro complejo sigma
y entonces otra vez la presencia de este
sustituye ente med occ si con el par
libre de electrones justo al lado de
nuestro anillo aromático nos da una
estructura resonante extra
esta es nuestra estructura resonante
extra y entonces tenemos un total de
cuatro estructuras resonantes para un
ataque corto y entre más estructuras
resonantes puedas dibujar
más estará deslocalizada esa carga
positiva y entre más estable sea tu
complejo sigma es más posible formar un
mecanismo de sustitución electro filic
aromática y entonces ya que podemos
dibujar cuatro estructuras resonantes
para un ataque [ __ ] ese es un kart
vocación favorecido ese es un complejo
sigma estable y eso se formará mucho más
fácil
y por supuesto el último paso en nuestro
mecanismo es protón ar tu complejo sigma
para formar nuevamente tu anillo
aromático pero no mostrar ese paso aquí
sólo quería ver las cuatro estructuras
resonantes posibles para un ataque [ __ ]
eso es diferente a un ataque meta
continuamos viendo qué pasaría si
añadimos nuestro grupo nitro meta
la posición meta
sería por supuesto esta de aquí
usaríamos estos electrones para un
ataque núcleo físico y esto mueve a
estos electrones a nuestro oxígeno
continuamos mostrando el resultado de
nuestro ataque núcleo físico añadiendo
nuestro grupo nitro
a la posición meta si mostramos el grupo
nitro en la posición meta así resaltemos
estos electrones de aquí estos
electrones que vienen y forman un enlace
debería decir con ese nitrógeno quitando
un enlace de ese carbono de arriba
ese carbono de arriba obtendrá una carga
formal de más 1 y por supuesto tenemos
nuestros otros electrones en nuestro
anillo así estructura resonante podría
dibujar una estructura resonante para
este guión podría tomar estos electrones
y moverlos a aquí continuaremos
mostrando otra estructura resonante
tengo esos electrones moviéndose para
acá tengo estos electrones vi aquí aún
tengo mi grupo micro
en la posición meta y me sustituyen te
meto c's y original así
y ahora me carga formal de más uno está
en este carbono justo aquí para ahorrar
tiempo no relacionar con colores estas
estructuras resonantes puedo dibujar una
más cierto podría mostrar estos
electrones y moviéndose a acá y
continuamos dibujando esa estructura
resonante
tengo estos electrones y moviéndose a
acá tengo estos electrones y tengo me
sustituyen te meto 'csi'
tengo nuevamente mi grupo nitro
y por supuesto ahora mi carga positiva
se mueve a este carbono de aquí abajo y
eso es todo solo puedo dibujar tres
estructuras resonantes nuevamente el
complejo sigma es un híbrido de estas
tres estructuras resonantes y ya que
solo puedo dibujar tres solo un total de
tres estructuras resonantes para esta
situación este complejo sigma no es tan
estable como el que vimos para un ataque
corto el complejo sigma para un ataque
[ __ ] era más estable porque podíamos
dibujar cuatro estructuras resonantes y
aquí solo puedo dibujar tres continuamos
mostrando un ataque para
si quiero mostrar mi grupo nitro
agregándose a mi posición para aquí está
la posición para usaremos estos
electrones y cierto un ataque núcleo
físico quita a estos electrones
esto sería nuestro ataque para
añadiendo nuestro grupo nitro en la
posición para nuevamente tengo mi grupo
med occ si esta vez mostraré mi grupo
nitro en la posición para
continuamos siguiendo estos electrones y
estos electrones y de aquí esos
electrones espín formaron un enlace con
ese nitrógeno
y quite un enlace de este carbono ahí es
dónde estará mi carga formal de 1
aún tengo estos electrones en mi anillo
así una estructura resonante para ésta
podría mostrar estos electrones de aquí
moviéndose para acá y veamos que
obtendríamos aún tenemos
nuevamente se sustituyen t
nuestros electrones se movieron para acá
estos electrones phil estaban acá tenía
mi grupo metro
para
y ahora quite un enlace de este carbono
ese es el carbono que obtiene la carga
formal de +1 puedo dibujar otra
estructura resonante podría mostrar
estos electrones de aquí moviéndose para
allá hagamos un poco más de espacio aquí
para más estructuras resonantes
puedo mostrar mi anillo y puedo mostrar
que estos electrones se han movido a acá
aún tengo me sustituyen t
y por supuesto mi grupo nitro
aún está en la posición para
de un enlace de este carbono obtuve una
carga formal de más 1 y nuevamente la
presencia de ese par libre de electrones
en ese oxígeno justo al lado de mi
anillo de benceno me permite dibujar
otra estructura resonante
podría pensar en estos electrones en mi
oxígeno moviéndose a acá para formar un
enlace pi y empujar estos electrones acá
abajo y entonces puedo dibujar una
cuarta estructura resonante ahora
mostrando el oxígeno doblemente enlazado
a mi anillo aún hay un par libre de
electrones en ese oxígeno lo que le dará
una carga formal de más 1 aún tengo
electrones pi aquí mostré electrones
moviéndose para acá y nuevamente mi
grupo nitro aún está en la posición para
y tengo un total de cuatro estructuras
resonantes si muestro el grupo nitro
agregándose en una manera para también
el ataque para también tiene cuatro
estructuras resonantes y el [ __ ] tenía
cuatro estructuras resonantes y eso
ayuda a explicar por qué el sustituyen
teme talks y funciona como un director
corto para
si muestras un ataque corto a uno para
poder dibujar un total de cuatro
estructuras resonantes lo cual
estabiliza al complejo sigma más que un
ataque meta y esa es la razón de la
región química que vemos en la migración
del med occ si vence no ahora dibuje
estas estructuras resonantes porque
empecé con mi anillo de benceno empecé
con mis electrones en esta posición de
aquí
ahora si empezaste con un anillo de
benceno diferente una estructura
resonante de eso entonces sus
estructuras resonantes podrían verse un
poco diferentes de las mías y verás
diferentes versiones en diferentes
libros de texto así que asegúrate de
nuevamente siempre ver lo que tu
profesor hace en la clase o en tu libro
de texto y piensa en eso en los exámenes
si es que te harán dibujar estructuras
resonantes para un ataque corto para o
meta